[SPEAKER_00]: As Folsom ran down the dock away from the boat that Owen Black and his Toli friend Torus were on, Torus watched him run.
[SPEAKER_00]: Behind him, Owen Black, recovering from the shot of rum that Folsom had thrown in his eye, walked up next to his compatriot and looked at the fleeing figure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Torus looked at him and said,
[SPEAKER_00]: We should go after him.
[SPEAKER_00]: We cannot allow him to get to his friends if they're still alive.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen looked at Torus and said, Unfortunately, I poured him the special draught.
[SPEAKER_00]: Torus looked at him with concern and said, And that got in your eye?
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen said, well, and Torus continued, I told you that was dangerous stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should not give that to anyone you have care for.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen, wiping his eyes, said, I just meant to knock him out for a few hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just enough time to get him to Kane-Toli's island without having troubles with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's a wily fellow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very charismatic, and his tongue is silver.
[SPEAKER_00]: He would talk his way out of most things, as you can tell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, I feel it's affecting me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I must go lay down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Torus says, Well, this is a fine fix.
[SPEAKER_00]: What am I to do now?
[SPEAKER_00]: I know not what these men look like.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know only this young whelp that you've brought to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do I deal with this right now?
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen lays down and he goes, We don't deal with it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let the Earl of Redshore deal with it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure that these men, if they have survived the night, have bloodied more than one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go to our normal contact with the Earl.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give him coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tell him that there are smugglers in town.
[SPEAKER_00]: Give him the location of my sloop.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's in the end of the dock that we normally use.
[SPEAKER_00]: They may be there, they may not.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, if they are going to escape, that's the way they will take.
[SPEAKER_00]: The arrow will do what's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's been murder in the city.
[SPEAKER_00]: He will send his men down there, even if the Marines have not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Once they learn that they're smugglers from Monmurg, he might get the Navy involved.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever the case, it's out of our hands now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no desire to cross swords with any of these men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Two, because I love them.
[SPEAKER_00]: One, because he's a killer.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to lay down now.
[SPEAKER_00]: The poison, it's starting to take effect.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen, grabbing a rag and dipping it into a dirty bucket of water, wiped his face.
[SPEAKER_00]: Says, Gods, this is powerful.
[SPEAKER_00]: I wonder what drinking it would be like before he laid down in the bunk, the lamplight flickering as he did.
[SPEAKER_00]: Torus looked at him and shook his head, knowing full well that Owen Black would be unconscious now for at least eight hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: A normal man's rest, but in this state there would be no waking him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Owen had meant to poison Folsom with the gift of Insamiar.
[SPEAKER_00]: If just a small amount, but still, that was a powerful concoction, not something to be given lightly.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was afraid that Owen Black probably was at the end of his usefulness.
[SPEAKER_00]: Once the gift of Insamiar took hold, as it probably would with a man exposed as he was, it would be the end of him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He would crave more of it, need more of it, and soon become unacceptable as servant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh well, Torus thought.
[SPEAKER_00]: Best keep him alive, for now.
[SPEAKER_00]: His idea of contacting the Earl of Redshore was not a bad one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let Redshore's minute arms deal with the problem.
[SPEAKER_00]: After all, these Monmurgian spies, even if they did work for the spymaster of Lord Jeon, they would be enemies of the state.
[SPEAKER_00]: Again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let Red Shore and Jameis think each other's enemies, for on paper and in reality they were, even though neither of them had the idea exactly how far they were being manipulated.